Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
for
So continuing in the chapter regarding
the virtues of knowledge,
a very critical narration which is a
guideline to those who have
achieved or earned or were blessed with
said knowledge.
We mentions a narration on the authority
of collected by
Abu Dani and
Abu Isa in his j.
They both narrate on the authority of
Abi that the messenger of Allah. Wasam
said which translates to whoever is
asked about a knowledge a piece of
knowledge and then proceeds to conceal
it from the questioner. Allah
will harness him with a rain of fire on
the day of judgment.
Harness him with a rain. Rain not R
a I N. Rain R E I N. A rain. The
rain that is in the horse's mouth. Well,
that's actually called a bit in English.
Call it a bit. It's put in the horse's
mouth and then it's connected to the res
on either side so that the horsemen can
you know steer the horse and give the
horse direction.
So our prophet sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam tells us that if someone is
asked about a piece of knowledge and
they proceed to then conceal it from the
questioner on the day of judgment Allah
will harness him and reign him with
rains of fire.
Now in order to understand this
narration we need to understand the
premise.
The premise is concealing knowledge from
the people in order to maintain a
a level of authority over them to
continue to make yourself
to make yourself indisposed
indisposable to the people so that
others do not rise up with the people of
knowledge. I don't know how many of the
brothers here have worked in a field of
a trade. I worked as a tradesman for
many years as a welder and a fabricator.
And anyone who's worked in a trade,
whether it's carpentry or mechanic or
anything of the sort, even in culinary
in cooking,
the people who are masters of those
trades
usually do not divulge
the secrets of those trades very easily.
You'll work with them as an apprentice
for years, and they will. Some of them
go as far as to make their apprentice
leave or turn around while they do
particular things. Why? Because what's
going to happen? The apprentice is going
to learn. He's going to outgrow the
master. Then he's going to go off and
become the master's competition. Well,
we can't have that. But if we keep him
ignorant, he stays under our thumb. This
is the idea. This is the psychology.
You'll find this in every trade. I if I
had a if I had a nickel for every
tradesman I worked with that were very
talented, very skilled men in their work
that actively concealed
trade secrets and
you know ways of the trade in order
to keep me in the dark. I would be a
rather wealthy man today, right? This is
something that's common. And so our
prophet sallall.aii wasallam he was
described as not being this way. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala praised him in the
Quran when he said
[Silence]
and so
is someone who is very stingy, keeps
things to themselves, hoards things for
themselves. This knowledge is power.
This is truly power.
It has the keys of the dunya and the
hereafter in it. It has the keys of all
success in it. As a matter of fact, I
will blow your mind now with something
that I think few people really notice.
You will find often
that the great advances in science,
thought,
in trade, in all kinds of things, the
great advancements that civilizations
take is right on the heels of a
messenger being sent to them. Because
success,
elements of success can be stumbled
upon. Success in this dunya can be
stumbled upon by a person who does not
believe in Allah in the last day who is
not divinely guided. He may stumble upon
elements of success but all of the
elements of success altogether
that only comes from revelation only.
Even medicine, the scholars tell us that
medicine was always a knowledge that was
brought by the prophets and messengers
of Allah.
However, the Jews after Musam
started to teach the medicine of their
prophets
cheaply to everyone. And they used to
sell knowledge of medicine to every Tom,
Dick, and Harry, not for the purpose of
guidance of humanity. And it then
branched off into a separate discipline
separate from the disciplines and the
fields of the sciences of revelation.
And so big advances in in in medicine,
major advances in where did does armor
come from?
Armor that we wear, where did it come
from?
He was given incredible feats and
metallurgy that were not these are not
things you just stumble upon. These are
things that would take millions of years
to figure out without the guidance of
Allah's messengers.
And the idea that we're given usually is
we're given the graph of the monkey and
then the monkey starts to stand up
slowly. You know what I'm talking about?
And then he starts to walk upright and
then he's a Neandrithal with the
big forehead and he's got a club and
he's wearing a skin and then
suddenly he's, you know, standing up
straight and then suddenly it's a guy in
a business suit or it's, you know, Frank
from down the road or it's , you know,
Gary from next door, right? This is the
idea. The ideas that humanity was this
primitive race that slowly learned
as they evolved to come out of the trees
and become civilized. And that could not
be more further from the truth. Humanity
begins opposite of the rest of nature.
Humanity begins at the pinnacle and then
as their morality begins to erode their
societies begin to decay. And it is
exactly the opposite. We're often taught
that monotheism, the worship of
one god, the idea of the worship of one
god, that this is an evolutionary step
that all civilizations began with the
worship of many gods and then slowly as
they became more civilized and they
became more logical, they started to
worship one god. It is exactly the
opposite of that.
Adam was taught what?
So he was given all of these trades, all
of this knowledge before he was sent
down to the earth, carpentry and
metallurgy and many of these things. And
then they were advanced and pushed along
by prophets and messengers through time.
The point here
is that
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam tells
us that whoever is asked about a piece
of knowledge and then they conceal it.
Conceal it in the way we just described
for any of those reasons, Allah will
harness him with a harness of fire on
the day of judgment.
However, first we need to know what is
knowledge. What's meant by knowledge?
This is knowledge. This is the knowledge
that everyone has a right to. Right? But
it's not just any knowledge. Not even
knowledge of the Quran and Sunnah is
appropriate for every person at every
time and place.
If I sat up here in this chair every
night and started to
give a class instead of
I start to give a class on abstract
hermeneutics of right or the sciences of
the chains of narration or the sciences
of
what would happen is that an appropriate
subject matter for this kind of
gathering? No, of course not. I'd be
sitting here by myself eventually,
right? This is not appropriate
because
so whoever is asked about a knowledge
that is necessary for his journey to
Allah
and that knowledge is then concealed
then Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
harness him with a harness of fire on
the day of judgment. However, if someone
comes to ask about an issue in the
differences of opinion in the is this
considered knowledge
in this sense
something that a person needs. However,
if many times the major scholars
Abu Abdah
the great muhadith and and and scholar
of oftent
times would be asked about abstract
issues, peripheral issues on or even
hadith and he would say
Allah did not create you for this.
It is not okay for a doctor to give the
patient everything that he asks for. It
is only appropriate for the doctor to
give the patient what he needs.
And this is no different. So when a
person comes to ask the essence, the
nature is the natural order of things is
that he's given an answer. However, if
it is something that he
is too advanced for him or something
that will have an adverse effect, then
he cannot be answered. And so the answer
now is whoever is asked about knowledge
that is pertinent to his journey to
Allah and then the questioned the
scholar conceals it then he is in the
wrong. However, if the questioner asks
about something that is not pertinent
and necessary for his journey to Allah,
there is no obligation upon the scholar
to answer. As a matter of fact, the
obligation upon him is not to answer.
But Allah in a general sense says says
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]